you always hear like um people say Kobe
could could be difficult to play with
because he held everyone extremely
accountable
yeah he's you know he's sick yeah he's
like a sick competitive guy yeah
he didn't um
it was hard for him
to get along with guys that you know
didn't want it as bad as he did
right you come from a losing culture you
spent a year in Miami decent team
obviously with a young D Wade you get to
the Lakers just like Kobe have a chat
with you like hey shit's different no
but I knew Kobe before
before the um before we came Mr Lee kind
of was um raised
um
and the same AAU environment so it came
through up in the Adidas circuit and
with Sonny with Carroll
but playing with them is going to be
different right because it's like yo
yeah but even through before that he
came to um I remember I played against
him in um that NBA camp
the NBA had the best their top 100 camp
and I remember
in this true story I remember he was he
came walking on we were out of that
Princeton if I remember
I can't remember he came walking on on
the campus
remember we had no shades
this [ __ ] had one he had a
briefcase with him
what was in the brief I don't know
homework I don't know but I was just
like you know [ __ ] 17 years old
18 years old he got a briefcase with him
like he just looked real serious right
and um do you feel like
playing with him kind of helped make you
kind of like force you to kind of grow
up a little bit no it made me take my
you know my CR it made me yeah made me
shoot for a championship yeah you know
so
practice at 10 you know what I mean hey
practice over at 12 I'm not leaving till
three every day damn you feel me so
man I could say he but see like he
instilled that with me he didn't have to
say nothing right I got common sense I'm
like this [ __ ] is the best
[ __ ] league if this is what he
doing to stay sharp I think if I should
probably I could play
you know I got the talent enough to hang
out with him on my own but if I could
just follow and and take a little bit or
what he doing the habits the behavior
yeah maybe some of that star does a fall
off on me yeah because a lot of people
got the talent but it's the other [ __ ]
always the other [ __ ] the other [ __ ]
tally gonna take you so far
you could probably get away you know
three to 15 games you were getting
talented but if you wanna
40 50 60 games or the same [ __ ] being
consistent you're gonna have to work